alright let's talk about the one percent
you know President Obama has made it a
sort of cornerstone piece of his second
term that he wants income inequality to
be a major issue that we're talking
about and he wants to change the rising
gap between the rich and the poor well a
new study has come out that highlights
the growing income inequality in the
world and shows that the 85 richest
people in the world own as much wealth
as get this half of the world's
population the study found that the
richest 1% had a hundred ten trillion in
wealth which is 65 times the total
wealth of the bottom half of the
population the bottom half of the
population owned about 1.7 trillion or
about point seven percent of the world's
wealth according to the report that's
the same amount as owned by the 85
richest people and finally the richest
1% in the US have received ninety-five
percent of the wealth created since 2009
after the financial crisis so obviously
this is a perfectly legitimate thing for
President Obama to be going after and
it's not just happening in America it's
happening all over but we're Americans
so let's start with America is is this a
legitimate it can he do this this this
to me seems like this in the NSA did
seemed to be the big things at least for
me is this something that he can truly
tackle cuz he hasn't really tackled it
he's saying it now but it's only gotten
worse in the last five or six years I
think it's just interesting that he
would mention it at all considering what
you go up against for having done so
unless you're just you're just playing a
card game on us and then you're not
going to do it and just we hold because
you say stuff we stay in place and pause
and don't do anything active waiting to
see if you'll do it instead we like good
speech hearing Mary yeah yeah and it
will he'll say the kind that will go
right here and right now wait what huh
okay well maybe we don't need to be
angry for 15 minutes here we wait so I
have no idea he is he's going up against
the single most powerful and dangerous
thing that earth has ever produced
there's the a-bomb and there's the this
group of people there the other thing
that can wipe out millions of people so
how angry a weapon of mass destruction
so how angry should we be at these
people because I think there's a little
bit of a danger
of totally demonizing them I don't have
a list of all 85 of them I'm sure some
of them give tons back and do good work
and all kinds of stuff I mean well they
need to protect sporadic in the Cayman
Islands ago yeah but can we be without
having this the exact list of these
people like how angry can we be at them
personally for just doing what the
system allows them to do I don't think
it depends what what their means were in
getting there and what they do with it I
think I mean we can't be we can't hate
we can't hate on those hustles you know
if they earned it they earned it you
know and I I do think that it's a fairly
lofty goal for Obama especially being in
the second term I don't really know the
means he's going to use to try to get to
an end result and also on top of that
you know I like that they're planning on
inviting some of these people to like
basically a forum discussion to try to
figure out how to resolve that I don't
know how well that's going to go over
it's like you know let's talk about how
we can make you less rich like it even
right now all the world's government
leaders are meeting in Davos and it's
all the richest people deciding with
politicians how do we keep the system
going and then you know people protest
but nothing really changes already got
mad at a politician you realize you're
shouting at the front desk receptionist
right she'll just tearfully you know
send the say this thing I have because
it's not that they the people that
bought and funded and installed
politicians are the ones that are
actually controlling all the events like
over there and they're not all evil and
I think there probably is some wisdom
and saying that there's probably a shred
even in your sociopathic little head of
a conscience that's starting to be
awakened by just watching the news yeah
that alone could bother you and give you
a sleepless night and I'd love to see
some of them wake up internally I'd love
to see the disillusion Adi step up and
start to go hey wait a minute I'm made
of salt water and I live on the planet
that's being destroyed right now yeah
it's part of the problem that it's just
never enough you think for these people
it's just never enough I mean if you own
that much well you can literally do
anything that a human being can do but
it's sort of like it just becomes this
game sort of now you think it's like
it's just financial game to them I mean
I think that some people some people
it's a game and I think that there's
others that they
just we're kind of like the nerds in
school that happened to bank on their
their creative genius or whatever you
know and it's just like they give back I
mean you look at Bill Gates and whatnot
you know he can never spend all the
money he's got but he gives back as much
as he can i think and it's just kind of
like it keeps coming in so what am i
going to do with it how does one
disperse this wealth equally to do for
the better good of humanity right this
way if you got rich making a product you
need the customers to have enough money
to buy your product yeah that's the
baseline and then I think it's the
extension of royalty I think what this
is is this is the whole point of royalty
is not just that I have is that you
don't have Oh what's the use if you have
a just a slightly crappier version of
what i have i'm not really royal you
have to completely not have what I have
I get to do what you can't do and
royalty has just been clever enough to
rename itself as oligarchy now yeah but
I think that they're using the royalty
rule and I think it's woken earth up to
seeing that that is a failed system
globally all at once and so I think
that's the upside and it just looks ugly
and horrible right now because we're in
the midst of it's still being in
existence but enough people are but no
people just talk about it well that's it
right and that's why it's a beautiful
thing that we can do this on youtube
where people all over the world can hear
about it cuz certainly even if you're in
America they don't talk about this kind
of stuff on CNN so one of the things we
talked about a couple weeks ago is that
is part of the problem also that the one
percent we always talk about the one
percent here the one percent in if
you're in America the one percent it's
around 250,000 dollars now that's not
obscenely rich by by any estimation so
it's part of the problem that we're yes
of course you're doing well at that but
you could live in New York City and
$250,000 doesn't actually get you that
far you know it really does in tiny
little place so is part of the problem
that the one percent number has just
become because it's catchy has caught on
when really we should be talking about
the point 0 0 0 1 percent and not the
one person because it's the people that
have hundreds and hundreds of millions
of dollars right it's not that the
250,000 yeah no I mean I mean there's a
huge gap between somebody that's earning
just above that one percent 250 and like
Bill Gates or Betancourt from you know
l'oreal or whatever visit
huge gap yet they're all clumped into
this one category i mean i think that
that's the same as like you know lumping
you in with some somebody in the slum
village in India or something you know
what I'm saying there's just a huge gap
it's hard to economics are pretty close
to those people actually this is
independent news here I don't know what
you think we're doing here like I don't
know yeah I mean you had water in a
couple wasn't in a bottle it was just
looking I was like well I did get water
in a glass yeah I have this jacket that
says 99 percent on it yeah and i was at
trader joe's on this guy he's very
nicely dressed ela Jordan he goes oh so
you're in the 99 percent that what you
think you aren't you think the one
percent Shops at Trader Joe's trader
guys is pretty good but all right so
last point on this and this is basically
what you were saying about their
receptionist so this is all about money
in politics and we keep yelling at the
politicians but it's really about all
the people that are pulling the strings
beyond that so what can we actually do
is it is it really getting money out of
politics first is that actually that's
absolutely that's the starting critical
I don't there's not a lot of other
things that are more important than that
if you want to talk about the politics
politics representing the people or not
represented people just representing a
few people and that is the
differentiation line between the two
when FDR's day he would take war
profiteers with their fancy leather
chair and have feds lift him and chair
and March them in front of film cameras
out of the building that's how they used
to treat that version of an oligarch
back then in that era they went all
we're never going to permit that to
happen against start buying your
politicians from here on it yeah so do
you think the system can ever change can
we ever get back to a place where we
have braved politicians like that and
really we don't even talk about campaign
finance anymore or anything like that no
but I mean the thing is even though they
did drastic actions like that I feel
like this type of thing this economic
gap has been going on for so long and
it's a global epidemic I don't know how
we're gonna have that I don't think all
of a sudden we've had this epiphany man
like we need to start taking action now
and now it's going to be like a resolved
thing I think it's going to be a very
long process if it is even that I think
it's I I want to be hopeful but I don't
know if that's
realistic well said and if you guys want
to do a little something about money in
politics check out wolf pack which a lot
of our young turks people know about a
rage